[Musique]
mélanie studio bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidate aux élections législatives où
vous présenter dans le sud sur la lys
combat ouvrier alors pourquoi d'abord
vous présentez vous à ces élections
législatives en se présentant aux
élections législatives car effectivement
nous vivons dans un système capitaliste
dans une société qui ne profitent qu'au
grand patronat qu'aux grandes
entreprises qu'aux plus riches y compris
les plus riches des antilles et les
travailleurs et la population pauvre
subissent en fait les mots de ces
sociétés subissent la précarité les
baisses de salaires le lait baisse aussi
de moyen dans la fonction publique bref
la baisse partout et donc du coup nous
on dit qu'effectivement si on veut
améliorer notre sort améliorer notre
avenir il faut absolument qu'on se bat
contre cette société alors quels sont
les deux ou trois projets prioritaires
pour la martinique que vous comptez
défendre si vous êtes élu à l'assemblée
nationale ce que nous défendons c'est un
programme de lutte nous disons qu
effectivement les salaires baissent il
faut absolument augmenter les salaires
et augmenter les salaires en même temps
que les prix augmentent et pour cela il
faut qu'on se bat pour imposer que les
prix augmentent en même temps que les
salaires il faut qu'on se bat aussi pour
augmenter pour augmenter les salaires et
minimum 2000 euros par mois pour tous
qui est salaires pensions et retraites
car effectivement en deçà de ceux de
1000 euros il n'est pas possible de
ville un tant soit peu des sarments il
faut absolument aussi qu'il y ait une
répartition en fête du travail entre
tous c'est à dire que le chômage est un
véritable fléau la précarité aussi et
donc du coup il faut absolument qu'on
répartisse le travail à la fois qu'on
travaille moins et qu'on travaille tous
et aussi il faut absolument que les
travailleurs imposent leur contrôle sur
le fonctionnement des grandes
entreprises car effectivement ces
grandes entreprises augmentent les
salaires augmentent pardon les prix
disque effectivement ils peuvent pas
augmenter les salaires et c est dans ce
cas qu'ils nous montrent qu'il nous
montre ce qu'il y a dans leurs comptes
pour qu'on puisse effectivement savoir
si l'entreprise est en difficulté ou pas
à vous présenter dans le sud concernant
cette circonscription dans laquelle vous
vous présentez quels seront alors vos
deux ou trois priorités
en tant que député ce sont les mêmes les
mêmes priorités qu'il ya dans toute la
martinique stasio la répartition du
travail entre tous l'augmentation des
salaires et surtout
abolir le secret bancaire et et ses
trois axes aulas il faudra que les
travailleurs et la population pauvre
l'imposent par des luttes je prends
l'exemple du sud par exemple
toutes les écoles du sud ne sont pas aux
normes parasismiques on baigne dans ce
cas il faut embaucher du monde il faut
répartir le travail entre tous pour que
toutes ces écoles soient reconstruites
aux normes parasismiques alors qu
avez-vous d'autres à dire aux électeurs
nous ne travaillons au pied déjà voilà
nous appelons l'ensemble des électeurs à
voter pour nous aux élections
législatives et à voter pour nous pour
combat ouvrier mélanie studio dans le
sud avec louis alexandre comme
remplaçant pour affirmer effectivement
que nous vivons dans une société qui ne
marche pas pour nous et qui nous
appauvrit qui effectivement nous mettre
dans des situations déplorables si
effectivement on y d'accord avec cela et
qu'effectivement il faut qu'on se batte
faut qu'on se batte pour augmenter les
salaires pour répartir le travail entre
tous pour qu'il y ait moins de chômage
bas effectivement si on est d'accord
avec cela et qu'il faut au bout d'un
moment rendez ainsi ce système
capitaliste et bien effectivement il
faut voter combo vrille mélanie studio
merci